[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى لنبدا
هذه الجوله من بلده رانشتاين غربي المانيا
حيث تناول وزراء الدفاع في دول النيدو
وبقيه البلدان الداعمه لاوكرانيا
لكيف في هذه المرحله الحساسه من الحرب
ومن العاصمه الصوماليه مقديشو تاتينا هذه
الصور في وقت يشهدوا فيه وسط البلاد موجه
جديده من المواجهات بين قوات الحكومه
وحركه الشباب المجاهدين
اما بيروت فاتصلنا منها هذه الصور في وقت
يزداد فيه الاستياء من ازمه شهور منصب
الرئيس بعد مغادره ميشيل العون قصر عبده
دون اختيار لخلف الله
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
خلال اجتماعا للاعبيه اوكرانيا في
رانشتاين تباين في المواقف حديث عن تكثيف
المساعدات
بدبابات متطوره
امر يحتاج مزيدا من القتال
القوات الروسيه سيكون صعبا هذا العام
مع اقتراب المعارك من باكموت كاميرا
الجزيره ترصد من داخل المدينه الاستعدادات
الاوكرانيه للمواجهه البريه
تسيطر على بلدات جنوب المدينه لقطع خطوط
الامداد الاوكرانيه
وتتحدث عن توتر والجيش الروسي بسبب
التنافسي في مناطق المعارك باوكرانيا
محكمه العدل الدوليه تكشف عن تلقيها طلبا
من الامم المتحده لابداء رايها بشان
التبعات القانونيه لاحتلال اسرائيل اراضيه
فلسطينيه بدات تهديد نتنياهو بالرد على اي
تحركات فلسطينيه على الساحه الدوليه واكثر
من 30 دوله تعرب عن قلقها من اجراءات
انتقاميه اسرائيليه ضد الفلسطينيين
في لقاءنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قدنا نقشنا معكم قرار شركه
جوجل الاستغناء عن خدمات 12,000 موظفين
وعامل بسبب تراجع والدتها الماليه وقد سبق
لشركات تكنولوجيه عملاقه اخرى مثل
الفيسبوك انستغرام تويتر امازون ان اعلنت
تسريحه الاف العمال وتعزو تقارير هذا
الامر الى تضخم كوادر الشركات المعنيه
خلال فتره انتشار وباءنا نظرا للطلب
المتزايد انا ذاك على خدمات الانترنت
الاستطلاع يا رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم قبل قليل السؤال الثالث
الكبرى لتسريح الالاف من عمال
72% قالوا ان الامر يعود لركود الاسواق
بسبب عوامل خارجيه مثل كورونا وحرب
اوكرانيا
وقال احد عشر بالمائه ان السبب هو بناء
خطط خطط المنافسه على اسس غير سليمه فيما
ذهب 17 بالمائه الى ان السبب هو وجوده
فائض في العماله لدى هذه الشركات الكبرى
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه لقاء على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربي ودوليا
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
المواجهات بين القوات الصوماليه وحركه
الشباب تتصاعد المعارك وتتركز في وسط
البلاد واكله طرفين يعلن تكبير الاخر
خسائر فادحه
[موسيقى]
دون اتفاق واضحا وحاسم انتهت اجتماعات
وزراء الدفاع في دول النيدو وبقيه البلدان
الداعمه لاوكرانيا في بلده رانشتاين غربي
المانيا وقال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ليس لديها اي اعلان جديد بشان تزويد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات هذا الاجتماع رفقه
سجال حول ارسال دبابات الامريكيه والمانيه
الى اوكرانيا
نظره قريبه من التحالف الاوروبي الامريكي
الداعم لاوكرانيا قد تشي ان بعض التصدعات
تشوب تماسكه فاجتماع الدول الداعمه في
قاعده رمشتاين الجويه في المانيا كشف عن
مخاوف بعض الدول الاوروبيه من نوعيه
الاسلحه التي ترسل الى اوكرانيا الدبابات
تحديدا الطريق الى رمشتاين سبقها سجلات
بين المانيا وحلفائها في اليوتيوب حول
ارسال دبابات
بدايه نقل عن المستشار الالماني قوله
لنرسل او نسمه بارسال دبابات الى اوكرانيا
قبل ان ترسل الولايات المتحده دباباتها
ليعود المتحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه
ويقول ان برلين لم تربط ابدا ارسل دبابات
القتاليه الالمانيه الى اوكرانيا بارسال
الولايات المتحده دبابات ابرامز
ذلك نفي وزير الدفاع الالماني
بورسبيستوريوس عرقله التسليح قائلا ان اي
قرار في هذا الشان لم يتخذ بعد ويجب تقييم
ايجابيات وسلبيات هذه الخطوه بعنايه شديده
اما الولايات المتحده فتستمر بتقديم
تفسيرها في عدم ارسال دبابات ام واحد الى
اوكرانيا
ان بلاده لم تتخذ قرارا بعد بخصوص دبابات
للبرد
على الرغم من الضغوط التي تمارس على
المانيا لارسال الدبابات تتشارك برلين
وباقي دول اوروبا في الخشيه بنحتمال
استعمال كياس اسلحتها الثقيله في ضرب عمق
الاراضي الروسيه ما يعني توريطها بحرب
هجوميه وليست دفاعيه خاصه تلك التي تملك
حدود مباشره او قريبه مع روسيا ومن هنا
يمكن فهم حذر المانيا التي لا تزال مطارده
باخطاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وبينما يستمر السجال للتحذيرا مفاده ان
تسليم اسلحه بعيده المدى لاوكرانيا يعني
انني ساعه سيبلغ مستوى جديده في الاثناء
تصرك ياف على حاجتها للدبابات ان ارادت
تعزيز قدراتها الميدانيه لا سيما في مناطق
الاشتباك القريبه
العمل من اجل توفير دبابات حديثه ولا بديل
عن اتخاذ قرار بشان ذلك واضافه المسائيل
يومي ان اجتماع
سيعزز قدره اوكرانيا على الصمود وانه خرج
بنتائج وصفها بالمهمه
اوكرانيا بكل ما يلزم حتى تحقيق النصر لا
يزله يتعين علينا النضال لتوفير دبابات
حديثه لكننا نوضح كل يوم انه لا بديل عن
ضروره اتخاذ قرار في هذا الشان اشكر جميع
الشركاء الذين دعموا بوضوح الموقف
الاوكراني هناك نتائج جيده بالنسبه لتوريد
المدرعات
وستضاف مئات منها لترسنتنا اضافه لنتائج
مهمه في ما يتعلق بالقضاء في الصاروخيه
والمدافع المضاده طائره
هذا وقد قال رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه الجنرال مارك ميلي انه سيكون من
الصعب دحرو القوات الروسيه خلال السنه
الحاليه من كل جزء احتلته في اوكرانيا
مضيفا في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع وزير الدفاع
الامريكي في قاعده اينشتاين الامريكيه في
المانيا ان الحرب في اوكرانيا يجب ان
تنتهي على طاوله المفاوضات على غرار
العديد من الحروب في العالم مؤكدا ان
الدعم لاوكرانيا سيستمر ما دامت الحرب
مستمره
سوف
العسكريه سيكون من الصعب نحو القوه
الروسيه من كل جزء احتلته في اوكرانيا هذه
السنه قد يحدث ذلك وقد لا يحدث لكن الامر
سيكون صعبه للغايه ما يمكن حصوله استمرار
العمل الدفاعي لمحاوله الثبات على الجبهه
ويتوقف ذلك على التدريب لتمكين
الاوكرانيين من رفع المستوى العمليه
والتكتيكيكي لتحرير اكبر عدد ممكن من
المناطق وفي نهايه الامر يجب ان تنتهي هذه
الحرب مثل العديد من الحروب على طاوله
المفاوضات وسيبقى الامر بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
امم فريق وينضم الينا من برلين رودريتش
كريوستير عضو لجنه الخارجيه في البرلمان
الالماني اهلا وسهلا بك
هل هل فعلا تبدو المانيا متحفظه او متردده
في تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات المطلوبه
شكرا شكرا
من الاشخاص والجنود وهم يتوقعون المزيد من
او معدات واسلحه افضل ودبابات لكي
يستطيعوا ان جاءته كل المؤشرات في الحان
المانيا كانت ستعطي
الرخصه لتصديري هذه الطائرات من الدول
الاخرى لكن المانيا متردده لانها تخشى ان
التهديد من روسيا وهو امر خاطئ وهو امر
مخيب للامام ليس فقط حلفائها في النيتو
لكن اعطى قوه مؤشر انه ليس هنالك قرار
موحد وموقف واحد اوروبي اوكرانيا وهو امر
مؤسف للغايه هل من امل في تعديل هذا
الموقف لاحقا
الحلفاء من حلف في الحكومه هم يدعمون هذا
الامر لكن هنالك تقطع في الصوت
لا احد يعرف لماذا هل هنالك تنازلات له
انه خوف يخاف انه لن يكون له فرصه للتفاوض
معه بوتين يعتق يعتقد ان ارائه غير واقعيه
في ما يتعلق بروسيا وهذا يدمر تماسك
التحالف المؤيد لاوكرانيا لسوء الحظ لماذا
لا نقول انه يخاف ان تكون هذه الحرب لا
طائله من وراءها وبالتالي كل هذه الاسلحه
في النهايه لا قيمه لها الانتصار اوكرانيا
على روسيا
ورشا روسيا قد هاجمه اوكرانيا كان هناك
مئات الالاف من الناس الذين قتلوا هنالك
اكثر من مئه الف الطفل
خرجوا خرجوا الى
تم تم اخراجهم من اوكرانيا الى روسيا من
اجل ان يتم تبنيهم وكانت اوكرانيا ايضا
جزءا من النظام الدولي لكنها حلقه ضعيفه
لذلك هجمتها روسيا فكره روسيا انه اذا ما
فشلت اوكرانيا في بامكانها ان تبدا الحرب
ضد ودول البلطيق بالتالي
نهزما روسيا من اجل ان توقف حربها
الاستعماريه هو حربها ضد الاتحاد الاوروبي
نحن هدف في هذه الحرب علينا ان نفهم مع
انتصرت روسيا هي ستبدا ايضا حربها في
اماكن اخرى في افريقيا وعلينا ان نكون
واضح حين ان روسيا في سوريا ترتكب جرائم
علينا ان نعرف ان روسيا تحاول ان تهزم
اوكرانيا لكي تظهر انه ليس هنالك اي فرصه
لاوكرانيا لكي تنجو وستكون نموذجا ايضا
لايران وايضا لكوريا الشماليه ولا الصين
من اجل ان يبداوا الحرب ضد الدول التي
تمثل تحديا في المجتمع الدولي ماذا عن
الراي العام الالماني هل يبدو متفاهما
لموقف للمستشار
للاسف
تجمدت الصوره
ننتظر ما اذا كان بالامكان ان يجيب
لا ليس ليس بالامكان وبالتالي ننتقل الى
ضيفنا الثاني يبدا ايضا هو ليس جائزا ربما
نعود اليه من واشنطن جيم
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
اذا نواصل هذه النشره النشره الحصاد في
سياقه عاد الينا الضيف اهلا وسهلا به اذا
اعيد السؤال في هذه الحاله عن توجهات
الراي العام الالماني ان كان متفهما لوجهه
النظر نظر المستشار
اذا هو عاده ولم يعد اذا نواصل نشرتنا
الحصاد في شيخ سياق الحديث عن المفاوضات
قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان الرئيس فلودي
ميرسي ناقشه مع نظيره التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بالتفاصيل الجهود الدبلوماسيه
اللازمه لتطبيقي صيغه السلام وفي الاتصال
الهاتفي بينهما اكد الرئيسان على مواصله
اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب وامكانيه توسيعها
الى موانئ اوكرانيه اخرى كما اعرب الرئيس
الاوكراني لنظيره التركي عن امله في
مساعده تركيه بعوده المعتقلين في روسيا في
المقابل قالت رئاسه الجمهوريه التركيه ان
اردوغان قرر عرض بلاده تقديم الوساطه
الدبلوماسيه القويه من اجل تاسيس السلام
الدائم بين روسيا واوكرانيا
قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكيه جون كيربي انه وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه ستصنف ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه
منظمه اجراميه عابره للحدود وانه سيتم فرض
عقوبات اضافيه عليها واضاف الكربون
لديها ما يقرب من 50,000 عنصر منتشرين
حاليا في اوكرانيا وان الرئيس الروسي اصبح
يعول عليها واكد كربي ان الاداره
الامريكيه بدات ترصد مؤشرات على زياده
التوتر بين الجيش الروسي وهذه الميليشي
ميليشه التي اصبحت مركز قوه المنافس للجيش
الروسي
ميدانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه سيطره
على بلده كلشيفكا الواقعه جنوبي بخموت في
منطقه دوناتس شرقي اوكرانيا وكانت ميليشيا
فاقن الروسيه قد اعلنت امس سيطرتها على
البلده التي تقع على بعد تسعه كيلو مترات
جنوبيه موت
كاميرا الجزيره
كيف يبدو المشهد في مدينه باخ موت شرقيه
اوكرانيا
مقاتلات اوكرانيه تسهم في سد الهجمات التي
لا تتوقف على المدينه
اهم ما نحصل عليه من المساعدات هي
المصابيح والكشافات لا كهرباء في المدينه
ولمياه ممتنين لكل من يسهم في تخفيف
المعاناه هذه اول مره ناتي فيها الى هذه
النقطه لكنهم يوزعون المساعدات يوميا
ان الاوضاع مقبله على منعطف سيكون له ما
بعدها
وشراسه المعارك في باقي المناطق توحي بان
الامر لن يكون سهلا
لذا شرعت الوحدات الهندسيه العسكريه في شق
الخنادق ورفع التحصينات وسط المدينه
هؤلاء الجنود مسرون على ان لا تكون مهمه
مهاجمين سهله
ويحرسون على زرع العقبه في وجههم بكل
الطرق الممكنه
في المدينه اتمنى ان لا نصل الى هذه
المرحله لكن اتمنى لا يكفي يجب ان نستعد
جيدا ارى ان الجميع يبالغ في امكانيات قوه
فاجنر هم مجرد لصوص المجرمين يحملون بنادق
ليس الا
ليست المدينه محاصره يقول الاوكرانيون
لكنها ليست في افضل حال وتحتاج الى تحضير
لمواجهه باتت محتمله
وتبقي جاهزيه المقاتلين مرتفعه في الميدان
بينما يتكفل اخر هنا بابقاء اعينهم مفتوحه
على كل تحركات المهاجمين مركز قياده
الاستطلاع في الجبهه الشرقيه
شاشات ترصد كل التحركات عبر مئات مسيرات
باختلاف احجامها
العين الساهره على الخطوط الاماميه كما
يسمونها
اكتسب العاملون هنا خبره كبيره مع
الوقتتهم دورا كبيرا لا يقل عن دور
المقاتلين في الخطوط الاماميه
[موسيقى]
والمدفعيه عن جبهه باخوت اعتماد العدو
قائم على المشاه الذين يخسروا الكثير منهم
كل يوم
هؤلاء المقاتلون
كما يملك كل جانب المدفعيه والدبابات
لكنما يميزهم هو السرعه اتخاذه من القرار
وقد هم من عزيمه يستمدونها من كونهم
يدافعون عن ارضهم عمر الحاجه الجزيره
مدينه ضخمه
وفي فقره المتابعه سنعود الى موضوع
الاسلحه النوعيه في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
محكمه العدل الدوليه طلبا رسميا من
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده بشان ابداء
الراي والتبعات القانونيه للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي للاراضي الفلسطينيه وفي بيانها
اوضحت المحكمه المسائل التي طلبت فيها
الامم المتحده الراي وهي تتبعات القانونيه
الناشئه عن الانتهاك المستمر من قبل
اسرائيل لحق الشعب الفلسطيني وحقوقه بشكل
عام وكيف ستؤثر سياساته وممارسته اسرائيل
على الجانب القانوني للاحتلال وما هي
اتبعات القانونيه التي تترتب على جميع
الدول والامم المتحده من هذا الوضع وياتي
بيان المحكمه بعد اعتماد الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده اواخر ديسمبر الماضي قرار
يطالبوا بشان الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه وقد
ادع اعتماده القرار الى اتخاذ اسرائيل
اجراءات عقبيه ضد السلطه فلسطينيه ما دفعت
39 دوله في الامم المتحده الى مطالبه
اسرائيل بالتراجع الفوري عن اي اجراءات
عقابيه
كما اعربت الامم المتحده حينها عن قلقها
اذا هذه الاجراءات مؤكده انه لا ينبغي ان
تتعرض السلطه الفلسطينيه الى اي اجراءات
انتقاميه
هذه الاجراءات الانتقاليه التي اتخذتها
حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحق السلطه
الفلسطينيه كانت ردا على التوجه
الفلسطينيه لمحكمه العدل الدوليه للحصول
على راي قانوني بشان استمرار عمليات الدم
التي ينفذها الاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه
فقد قررت اسرائيل الخصم نحو 39 مليون
دولار من عائدات الضرائب المستحقه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه وتحويلها لعائلات الاسرائيليين
اصيبوا في عمليات نفذها فلسطينيون كما
جمدت السلطاته الاسرائيليه اعمال البناء
للفلسطينيين في المناطق المصنفه جيم في
الضفه الغربيه كما سحبت التصاريح الدخول
لشخصيات فلسطينيه هامه
وزير الخارجيه رياض الملكي والسفير
الفلسطيني في الامم المتحده رياض منصور
وزياد ابو عمر المستشار الخاص للرئيس
الفلسطيني كما لوحه اسرائيل باجراءات
الانتقاليه اخرى في حق اي جهه او منظمته
في الضفه الغربيه تروج لاي نشاط ضد
اسرائيل قانونيا او سياسيا كما هددت بسحب
الامتيازات المقدمه لكبار الشخصيات في
السلطه الفلسطينيه ممن يقودون الحمله
الدوليه القانونيه والسياسيه ضد اسرائيل
انضم الينا من لندن توبيكاد من المحامي
المتخصص في القانون الدولي اهلا وسهلا بك
لماذا تبدو اسرائيل مرتايبه الى هذا الحد
من
اللجوء الى محكمه العدل الدوليه
من قبل الجمعيه العامه
ثانكيو
مما رايناه من اسرائيل خلال الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه خلال التصويت على الجمعيه
العامه كان هجوما على فلسطين لذلك هم في
اسرائيل تشعر بالقلق الكبير من ان محكمه
العدل الدوليه
ليس لديهم لديهم حق تقرير المصير وان
الاحتلال غير قانوني وان الاستمرار في
عمليات بناء المستوطنات هو امر غير قانوني
بالتالي نعم بالتاكيد اسرائيل قلقا كبير
وهي تحاول ان تمنع استمرار هذا الامر
عام 2004 محكمه العدل الدوليه اصدرت حكمها
في موضوع الجدار الفاصل في الضفه الغربيه
ومع ذلك اسرائيل لم تعر وزنا لذلك ما الذي
يجعل هذه المره في وضع مختلف ربما
انه سيكون هناك قرار ياتي من محكمه العدل
الدوليه كما ذكرت في عام 2004 ايضا وا
اسرائيل
سترفض الالتزام بهذا القرار اعتقد ان هذا
امر محتمل بشكل كبير من الواضح ان الاسئله
التي السؤال الذي تم طرحه الان او القضيه
التي يتم مناقشتها مختلفه هنالك اجراءات
يتم اخذ نظر الاعتبار اعتقد ان علينا ايضا
ان ننظر الى حقيقه ان اسرائيل الان لديها
ربما
يمينيه همم متطرفه وهي تريد ان تدفع بهذه
الاجراءات
وتتبعوا ايضا سياسات فصل العنصري بالتالي
المجتمع الدولي قلق من هذه الاجراءات هو
الموقف مختلف
يختلفوا بشكل كبير عن مكان علي الحال عام
2004 وايضا هنالك ايضا للتحقيق في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه المستمر بالتالي الوضع
مختلف لا لا يجب ان نتوقع من اسرائيل ان
تلتزم باي قرار من المحكمه محكمه العدل
الدوليه لكن اعتقد انما ست- نقوم بهذا
الهمر هو اضافه ادانات دوليه على سياسات
الاسرائيليه وممارستها ضد الفلسطينيين
وهذا
الامر يصعب عليهم الامور اذا افترضنا بعد
30 يوم عادت محكمه العدل الدوليه بقرار
يعتبر فعلا ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للضفه
تحول الى ضمن فعلي
ما ما الذي على الجمعيه العامه ان تقوم به
في هذه الحاله
اذا
بنفسي الطريق التي حصل فيها قرار عام 2004
سيكون هنالك توصيات عديده ومن المحتمل ان
يعود الامر الى الجمعيه العامه في ذلك
الوقت لانه علينا يتم ناخذ بنظره الاعتبار
انه تم طرح اسئله عديده وكان هذا الامر
طالبا من قبل الجمعيه العامه من اجل تقديم
راييا استشاري من قبل محكمه العدل الدوليه
بالتالي النيه هو السؤال الذي تم طرحه او
القضيه النقاشه والطلب من المحكمه العدل
الدوليه الامر سيعود مره ثانيه الى
الجمعيه العامه والجمعيه العامه بامكانها
ان تقرر ما هي الاجراءات التي يجب اتخاذها
من بين الدول التي صوتت على قرار الجمعيه
العامه بالذهاب الى محكمه العدل الدوليه
نجد همم همم المملكه المتحده همم الولايات
المتحده المانيا كندا ايطاليا
هذه الدول ما مبررها في الاعتراض على
مساله تعود الى القانون الدولي وهم
يتحدثون عن القانون الدولي في موضوع
اوكرانيا مثلا
اختلاف كبير في راي الدول المختلفه وهنالك
ايضا مقاربه في الكثير من النفاق عندما
يتعلق الامر باوكرانيا ومقارنه بالممارسات
التي تقوم بها اسرائيل في الاراضي المحتله
لسوء الحظ هذا ليس بالامر الجديد رايناه
ايضا في الاداره الامريكيه فيما في عهد
ترامب ولم تتحسن الظروف كثيرا في اداره
ايضا في الحكومه همم البريطانيه والحكومه
الالمانيه ايضا تحاول ان تتمنى مقاربه
بنفسها عن الامر هذا من نواجهه لا استطيع
اجيب نيابه عن هذه الجمل ولماذا اتخذت هذا
هذه المقاربه اعتقد انها مقاربه خاطئه
واعتقد ان المجتمع الدولي يجب ان يتم
التطبيقه بدون تمييز لكن لسوء الح بشكل
مستمر مقاربات مختلفه يتم تطبيقها بشكل
مختلف عندما يتعلق الامر باسرائيل اسرائيل
يجب ان تتم محاسبتها كاي دوله اخرى همم
لكنها تستذكر الدراما تتحدث عن معادات
الساميه عندما يتعلق الامر بالقانون
الدولي لكن الاغلبيه صوتت لصالح هذا الطلب
وايضا بعد ذلك سيتم اصدار الراي ويعود
الامر الى الجمعيه العامه وست ستصدر
قراراتها
وهذا وقد اكدت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه بكل مؤسساتها مستعده
للتعاون مع محكمه العدل الدوليه في كل
تفاصيل هذه القضيه
الى لبنان الان ففي اخر فصول ازمه الفراغ
الرئاسي والاخفاق في انتخاب رئيس جديد
للبلاد اعتصم نائبا داخل البرلمان
للمطالبه بانتخاب رئيس جديد للجمهوريه
وقال النائب ملحم خلف ان وجوده وزميلته
النائبه نجاه صليبه داخل قاعه مجلس النواب
واجب وطني والزمي وفقا الدستور حتى
انتخابي رئيسا للبلاد
[موسيقى]
نحن علينا
هذا وقد انعكس شعور منصب رئيس الجمهوريه
في لبنان سلبا على المستويات السياسيه
والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه كافه وفي ظل
الانسداد السياسي والازمات التي تشهده
البلاد تعطلت مسارته اقرار خطط الاصلاح
الاقتصادي والمالي كما اصيب اغلب المؤسسات
الرسميه بالشلل واصيب الشباب بالياس الذي
عمق لديهم الرغبه في الهجره الى خارج
البلاد
يحاول لبنانيون جاهدين مواجهه الازمات
الاقتصاديه وارتدادات الانسداد السياسي
والشهور الرئاسي اما الشباب فيجدون انفسهم
في صراع بين واقع مرير يعيشون هو احلى من
تراودهم بمستقبل
في الاسواق الصوره ليست افضل حالا
هنا يشتري اللبنانيون ما تيسر فغالبيه هذه
المنتجات باتت خارجه امكاناتهم ارتفاع
اسعارها
يفرشها علينا بقى بكل شيء بكل شيء
متدحرجه لكن السلطات واجهتها بخطوات موعيه
قصيره عن وقفه لانهيار مع دخول الانهيار
الاقتصاديه عامه الرابع يعاني اكثر من نصف
قاتل لبنان من انعدام الامن الغذائي ويرون
ان السلطات المتقاعسه عن تنفيذ الاصلاحات
واعاده هيكله القطاع المصرفي وابرامي
الاتفاق النهائي مع صندوق النقد
على المستوى السياسي الانسداد السيد
الموقف والشهور في سوده الرئاسه يكاد يصيب
السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعيه بشلل
يترافق مع انهيار اقتصاديا غير مسبوق
عمليا
السلطه التشريعيه وهذا الشيء عم بيصير
بلحظه البلد احوج ما يكون الى السلطتين في
ظل تازهم اقتصادي اجتماعي مالي لازم
لبناني ياخذ قرارات سريعه وان لا يكون
مترددا في مواجهه
اقلوا الاشياء اللي طالبها صندوق النقد
الدولي
تتكاثر الازمات في لبنان وتتشعب ميادينها
اما السلطات المعنيه فتبدو عجزه عن
اشتراها حلول تستجيب لحاجات لبنانيين
ومطالبهم بالاصلاح وبناء الدوله كارلوس
خضار الجزيره بيروت
الكاتب الصحفي والمحل السياسي اهلا وسهلا
بك هل نحن امام تصاعد التململم في لبنان
جراء الشهور الرئاسي
كل الخطوط الحمراء يعني دخلنا في مرحله
الانسداد الكامل وعلى عتبه انهيار الكامل
وبالتالي هذا سين عكس المزيد من الياس
اولا على الشباب ثانيا على مجموعه
اللبنانيين يعني عمليه فقدان الثقه بين
المواطن وسلطه السياسيه يعني هي بالكامل
على المستوى السياسي لا اعتقد ان ان ممكن
حله في في القريب العاجل الصعصاء على
مستوى الداخلي لا حوار بين القوى السياسيه
همم لا خلافات تزداد اكثر واكثر الانقسام
الطائفي بلغ ذروته وبطبيعه الحال هناك
تغيرات على مستوى القوى السياسيه يعني
اليوم عندما نتحدث عن طلاق همم ممكن
ومحتمل بين حزب الله والتيار الوطني الحر
هذا ايضا سنعكس على كل العمليه السياسيه
وبالتالي يؤثر سلبا على احتمال انتخاب
رئيس جديد لجمهوريه وبالتالي الانسداد
داخلي وايضا هناك الاجواء العام الاقليميه
التي لا تبشر بالخير ابدا يعني كلنا نسمع
اليوم ما يحدث بين ايران والاتحاد
الاوروبي بين الدول المعنيه الاساسيه في
شان اللبناني وكلها قد تؤثر سلبا على
الداخل وعلى اي تسويه محتمله من شانها ان
تنقذ لبنان مما هو في فبالتالي كل الامور
اضافه الى الاهمال الداخلي العمليه
الانكار من القوه السياسيه هي لا تنظر الى
شيء سوى الى مصالحها الفرديه وبالتالي هذا
انعكس على المستوى المعيشي انعكس على
مستوى الاقتصاد على مستوى سعر الصرف الذي
على ما يبدو ان سعر صرف الدولار الى همم
حدود له اليوم 50 ربما في الايام المقبله
60 70 و100 وكلها هذا يعني دفع المزيد
اللبنانيين الى المزيد الياس والبحث عن
قارب نجاه يقول لهم من البلد الى الخارج
نصف شبابنا في الخ- في اثاره الخارج
اولادنا كلهم في الخارج اذا نظرنا الى همم
الجدول الديمغرافي اللبناني هناك فجوه
كبيره في اعمار الشباب بين 20 و40 سنه لا
نعرف كيف من سيملا هذا الفراغ وهذا كله
يؤشر الى ان مستقبل البلد ليس بخير نعم
هذا اللعب ال ال الاقتصادي والمعيشي على
الناس الا يشكل ضغطا على الطبقه السياسيه
للاسراع على الاقل في ايجاد تسويه ما
ابدا ابدا هم يعيشون حاله انكار كان شيئا
لم يحدث
كان لا يوجد مشكله في البلد اليوم من
يستمع الى حديث السياسيين يعني
الاخلافاتهم قبل كل شيء لا بل الحلول
المطروحه التي بدانا نسمعها في الايام
الاخيره مثل التقسيم مثل الفدراليه كلها
حلول من شانها اذا ما طبقت فعلا ان تزيد
الازمه تازيما اكثر يعني لا شيء يشير الى
ان هناك فحوى الضمير لدى ايا من هؤلاء من
شانه ان
يخفف من حده الازمه كان يمكن الجلوس عند
طاوله حوار لكن بسبب الخلافات بسبب ايضا
تحكم الخارجي
على ما يبدو ان هذه الطريق مدوده وهناك
ايضا عمليه اساسيه بدايه
التغيير هي بالاصلاحات هل من مصلحه هذه
القوه السياسيه ان تقوم بمثل هذا الاصلاح
هي تعرف تماما ان الاصلاحات من هذا النوع
من شانها ان تجرها الى المحاكم من شانها
ان تجرها الى المحاسبه وهي حتما لا تفكر
بمثل هذا الموضوع والامور تدرك تماما انه
اذا ما سقط حجر منها مثل لعبه الدومينو
سوف تتساقط الحجار الاخرى لذلك هي رغم
خلافاتها تدرك تماما ان عليها ان تتالف
لمنع
ان تحاسب لمنع اني ان يدخل طرف جديد على
الخط وبالتالي الامور بهذه الطريقه لا
تبشر بان شيئا جديدا قد يحصل في المدى
المنظور وحتى ولو كان هناك انتخاب برئاسه
رئيس الجمهوريه جديد وحكومه جديده حتما
بظل هذا النظام السياسي وظل هذه التركيبه
الحاكمه منذ عقود وعقود وحتى اليوم لا
اعتقد ان الامل
بشيء افضل همم امر ممكن شكرا لك امين
كموريه من بيروت
[موسيقى]
مصادر الدبلوماسيه في الخارجيه التركيه ان
انقر استدعت السفيره السويدي لديها
وسلمتها احتجاجا شديدا لهجه بشان منح
سلطات السويديه ترخيصا لحرق نسخ من القران
الكريم امام مقر السفاره التركيه في
ستوكهولم يوم غدا السبت حسب المصادر فقد
ابلغ السفير السويدي
تركيا
لا يمكن الدفاع عنها بداواعي الحقوق
الديمقراطيه كما ابلغ السفير السويدي بان
انقرا تعتبر السماحه لانصار حزب العمال
الكردستاني بالقيام باعمال دعائيه يوم غد
يعد خرقا واضحا للاتفاق الثلاثي الذي
وقعته تركيا مع السويد وفنلندا بشان
الانضمام
العامل الاتحاد التونسي للشغل نور الدين
الطبوبي ان لجانا من الاتحاد تعملوا على
بلوره تصورات في المجالات القانونيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والثقافيه
كمبادره للحوار الوطني الطبوب باضاف ان
تونس ليست مختبرا للتجارب على حد تعبيره
على ما هو تربوي واهميه التربيه وغيرها
هذه كل مش نشتغل عليه سنتقدم بمبادره
متكامله لناخذ فيها بعيدا اعتبار كل هذه
المجالات وكان الناس استجابت استجابت واذا
مؤسس الدوله لم تستجب لانه احنا قلت
نحترمه المقامات ونحترموا المؤسسات مش
بتاع فوضى ولكن اذا هذه المؤسسات ورموز
السكه المؤسسات اليوم على راسها رفضت ذلك
لكل حادث حديث
[موسيقى]
الصومال افادت وكاله الانباء الرسميه لان
سبعه جنود من الجيش الصومالي قتلوا في
هجوم لحركه الشباب على قاعده عسكريه في
قلعه
[موسيقى]
وسط البلد واضافه الوكاله ان القوات الجيش
صدت الهجوم على القاعده وقت مسلح من
الحركه من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم الحركه
عبد العزيز ابو مصعب ان مقاتله الحركه قتل
159 من افراد القوات الحكوميه بينهم ضباط
وانهم هاجموا القاعده من ثلاث جبهات والحق
اضرار كبيره
جوله جديده من المعارك بين الجيش الصومالي
وحركه الشباب في وسط البلاد صدى الجيش وفق
اعلانه هجوما لحركه الشباب على قاعده
عسكريه في مدينه قلعت تضاربت بيانات
الجانبين بشان خسائر كل طرف فبينما تقول
حركه الشباب انها قتلت 1559 من القوات
الحكوميه والحقت اضرار كبيره بعتاد
القاعده العسكريه بعد ان هاجمتها من ثلاث
جهات يؤكد الجيش مقتل سبعه فقط من جنوده
مقابل 100 من مقاتل الحركه واوردت وكاله
الانباء الصوماليه ان مدينه جلعت تحت
سيطره الجيش وان وضعها مستقر بعد صدمه
حركه الشباب تقع مدينه كالعاده التي شهدت
معارك الجمعه ضمن اقليم جلد دود وسط
البلاد وهي ليست بعيده عن سياق متصل من
الهجمات لحركه الشباب التي هاجمت يوم
الثلاثاء قاعده عسكريه اخرى في حوالي
باقليم شبيل الوسطى في الايام القليله
السابقه شهد اقليم هيران هجمات وتفجيرات
عديده لحركه الشباب خلفت قتلى وجرحى
تتابعوا هجمات الحركه مطلع العام الجديد
يبدو ردا على زخم لافه شهدتها جمال الجيش
الحكومي منذ منتصف العام المنصرم عندما
اعلن الرئيس الصومالي حسن شيخ محمود حرب
من شامله ضد حركه الشباب اواخر يوليو
استعاده القوات الصوماليه خمس مناطق من
قبضه مسلح الحركه في اقليم الشابيل الوسطى
وفي العشرين من سبتمبر استعاد الجيش من
طاقه ضوعه باقليم ايران بعد 13 عاما من
سيطره حركه الشباب عليها وانشاء قواعد
ومحاكمه فيها وفي السادس من ديسمبر اعلن
الجيش الصومالي استعاده مدينه ادلب باقليم
شبيل الوسطى ثم استعاد مع بدايه العام
الجديد خمسه مدن ابرزها مدينه
الاستراتيجيه باقليم مدغشق
على المحيط الهندي وهو ما اتاح للجيش
الحكوميه الوصول الى الطرف الشرقي
للاقاليم الوسطى يرى محللون امنيون
صوماليون ان حمله الجيش الحكومي لو مضت
على هذه الوتيره فلن يكون هذا في صالح
حركه الشباب حتى مع استمرار هجماتها
الرهينه
ومعنى من لندن مارتن بلوتوث الخبير في
شؤون القرن الافريقي بمعهد دراسات
الكومنولث اهلا وسهلا بك هذا الكر والفر
بين الجيش الرسمي وحركه الشباب كيف ترى
عايزين
اقول امرين كما ذكر تقريركم ان هذا كان
ردا على
الهجمات التي قامت بها قوات الحكومه خلال
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه التي كانت ناجحه
في طرد حركه الشباب من الاراضي التي يسيطر
عليها وايضا باستطاعتنا ان نقول ايضا اننا
لا يجب ان نصدق تقارير من الطرفين عندما
يتحدث عن خسائر الطرف الاخر اذا ذكر اي
طرف ان هذا
ذلك عدد معين قلت له منهم ستصدقوا هذا
العمل لكن دائما هنالك مبالغ في الخسائر
المتعلقه بالطرف الاخر لكن من الواضح ان
القتال مستمر
من تغيير مناطق النفوذ والسيطره وهذا
الامر ترك حركه الشباب في موضع ضعيفه وهم
يحاولوا ان يعكس هذا الامر طالما هناك
مبالغه من الطرفين كيف يمكن لنا ان نعرف
حقيقه الوضع على الارض
ويجب علينا ان نكون هناك ولا لن نستطيع ان
انا او انت ان نكون هناك لكن التقارير
واضحه فيما يتعلق بمساله وجود الكثير من
القتال اعتقد ان خسائر المدن مثل الديره
وايضا كانت منطقه سيطر عليها حركه الشباب
والحكومه
في موقع الهجوم ايضا كانت قطعت الكثيره من
الطرق الامدادات التي كان يستخدمها الشباب
مثلا همم حسابات مصرفيه كانت تعتمد عليها
حركه الشباب من اجل تمويل عملياتها لانها
شاب حركه الشباب
يفرضوا ضرائب على المحليين في السيطره وهم
يحتاجون هذا المال لشراء الاسلحه لكن همم
وهذه هي الطريقه التي يستخدمها لسنوات
عديده وتم حرمانهم من هذا الامر الان واضح
ان القبائل الصوماليه دخلت على خط هذه
المعارك هل تعتقد بان لها دور مؤثر في
سيرها
هي انه في ما ذكرته هو صحيح للغايه لكن
صحيح ايضا انه في المناطق التي يكون فيها
حركه الشباب قويه خارج المدن باستطاعتها
ان تخوفها الناس وبامكانهم ان يلتقوا
بكبار السن وحكماء
العقبهم وبالتالي تلك القبائل بسحب دعمها
من القوات الحكومي لانهم يعرفون انهم
سيواجهون الصعوبات كبيره وقد يقع في مشاكل
جمع عرضه حركه الشباب بالتالي هو قتال صعب
اعتقده لا اعتقد ان هذه المواجهه تنتهي
قريبا انها جمات عن طريق مسيرات هو امر
تخافه حركه الشباب الولايات المتحده
وتركيا كانت تجهز هذه السيارات
لقوات الحكوميه وهمم
بالرغم اذا حركه شباب الان في موقف د
لكنها لم تهزم ولا يعتقد اننا سنرى نهايه
قريبه لهذا الصراع
من لندن الخبير في شؤون القرن الافريقي
بمعهد دراسات الكومنولث
[موسيقى]
نعود الان لحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وثنائيه وعود الغرب ومطالب اكياف باسلحه
نوويه
من اندلاع الحرب يثور الجدل بين الحلفاء
الغربيين بشان ارسال الدبابات الالمانيه
التي ما زالت بحاجه الى موافقه برلين ليتم
تزويد الجيش الاخراني بها وقد تعهدت
بريطانيا الخميس بتزويد اوكرانيا ب 600
صاروخ اضافي من طراز
بتقديمه 19 مدفع قيصر في رمسيس السنه
والسويد
ويبلغ مدادها عشرات الكيلومترات لكن كيف
تطالب بان يكون هذا المدى ابعد من ذلك كما
ستزود واشنطن الاوكرانيين ب 95 مركبه من
طراز برازيلي ستضاف الى مركبه درعه خفيفه
من هذا النوع كان قد تم التعهد بها في
السادس من يناير الحالي فضلا عن 90 ناقله
جن مصفحه من طراز سترايكر تطالب كيف
بزياده مدى صواريخ منظومه هاي مارس التي
زودتها واشنطن بها يبلغ مدى هذه الصواريخ
حاليا نحو 90 كلم فيما تطالب بتزويدها
بنسخه يبلغ مداها 300 كلم لكن اداره ايضا
تعتقد ان توفير هذه الصواريخ بعيده المدى
يمكن ان يتسبب في تصعيد الحرب مع روسيا
هذا بالنسبه للاسلحه التي مازالت في خانه
الوعود اذا ما زالت في مستوى الموعود لكن
ماذا عن الاسلحه التي قدمها الغرب الى كير
مؤخرا وافقت بريطانيا على تزويد اوكرانيا
باربع 10 دبابه تشالنجر اثنان وهي دبابه
القتال الرئيسيه في الجيش البريطاني وكانت
واشنطن قد وافقت على تزويد كليب بمنظومه
صواريخ وقد وصلت فعلا قوات اوكرانيه الى
ولايه اكلهما الامريكيه لتتدرب على هذه
المنظومه
في حزيران العام الماضي وصلت الدفعه
الاولى من صواريخ هاي مارس الامريكيه الى
الجيش الاوكراني كما ارسلت واشنطن منظومه
صواريخ نيسانس ارض جوله اوكرانيا في
نوفمبر الماضي وكانت استراليا وكندا
والولايات المتحده من بين الدول التي
ارسلت مدافع هاوزر ان سبعه سبعه وذخيره
الى اوكرانيا كما قدمت تركيا طائرات بدون
طيار من طراز برقدار الى اوكرانيا ينضم
الينا من برنامج
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك
في ظل هذه
الترسانه من الاسلحه التي اعطيت او التي
مازالت في الطريق هل يمكن لها ان تؤثر
نوعيه في المعارك
الامكانيات التي سيتوفرها دبابات
البريطانيه وايضا مدفعيه
وايضا المدرعات التي توفرها المانيا وايضا
هو الامكانيات
الاضافيه
والقنابل ذات المدى المتوسط هو ايضا
والمدفعيه اذا ما كانت
همم المتحركه من قبل الجيش البريطاني
ستلعب دورا مهما وكل
ايضا عربات الدعم ستعطي الاوكرانيين ايضا
قدره على اختراق اي دفاع روسي الان يتم
التركيز على الدبابات في السابق كان هناك
التركيز على المسايرات هل الدبابات قادره
على ان تحدث تغييرا في معادله الحرب على
الارض
حقيقه الامر هذا الدبابات ستعطي اوكرانيا
امكانيات اضافيه على شان هجمات وعلى ان
تستمر بامتلاك المبادره التي ماكانتها من
السيطره على خارجي هيرسون في الجنوب
الشرقي لكي تستمر بهجمتها المضاده
واستعاده الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها القوات
الروسيه بطريقه غير قانونيه ايضا دبابات
البريطانيه هي تمثل جزءا صغيرا وايضا همم
ايضا الدبابات الفرنسيه الخفيفه ستلعب
دورا لكن ربما هي دبابات لبرد التي اذا
استطاع الالمان تجهيزها لاوكرانيا والدول
الاخرى ستلعب دورا مهما لان هذه الاهميه
تاتي من اعدادها همم الموجوده في دول
مختلفه بالتالي باستطاعته عده دواء الان
تسهم وايضا يجب التفكير بامكانيات
اللوجستيه والدعم اللوجستي من اجل
الاستمرار بتشغيل هذه الدبابات
الاسلحه تاتي من امريكا من المانيا من
فرنسا من بريطانيا الا يحدث هذا بلبله على
الصعيد الميداني في اوكرانيا
الامر يخلق صعوبه لن اقول بل بل هي صعوبه
لكن كل ما كان هنالك انواع مختلفه من
المعدات والمدرعات وبالتالي الدعم
اللوجستي سيكون مختلفا وايضا كل هذه
العناصر ربما سيزداد تعقيدا هذا هو التحدي
الاكبر لاوكرانيا هو ان ياتون
مختلفه همم بقطع الى الغيار الخاصه بها
وطريقه صيانتها وذخيرها ويستخدموها كوحده
واحده في القتال لحد الان هم يقوم بهذا
الامر بشكل جيد اعتقده ان هم يظهروا للغرب
وكيفيه العمل في ضمن منصات مختلفه كل ما
حصل على اسلحه اكثر كلما سيشعر الروس
بالخوف المانيا المتردد في موضوع الدبابات
هل يمكن ان يدق اسفين داخل وحده نيته في
موضوع اوكرانيا
حضرتك
انقسام او شاقا لكن النقاشات الموجوده ان
السياسات المحليه الالمانيه حيث ان الشعب
الالماني
يقولون
هم يعتقدون ان المانيا هي كانت بطيئه نوعا
ما في تقديم
الاسلحه لان بسبب العلاقات التاريخيه بين
المانيا وروسيا لكن اعتقد ان الالمان
سيسمحون لدول الاخرى لديها معدات واسلحه
المانيه بتجهيزها للاوكرانيين خلال وقت
قصير وقسمنا تعليقات مشابهه من وزير
الدفاع الالماني جديد
وايضا ربما بمرور الوقت فان الالمان
بالتالي
اكبر ربما بالدبابات هم يساهمون بعدد كبير
من المدرعات وايضا امكانيات المدرعه مثلا
همم هنالك المدافع او ايضا
المدرعات همم
المضاده للمدفعيه وايضا الكثير من المعدات
التي قدمها لاوكرانيا بالتالي
النقاشات حول الدبابات الان مثيره
للاهتمام لكنها اعتقد انهاست الى مرسى
تتغير مستقبلا شكرا
[موسيقى]
رياض منيمنا يحفظوا هذا الاسم جيدا الرجل
وهو الان على مشارف الثمانين من العمر لم
يتخلى عن ممارسه الرياضه وليس اي رياضه
انها رفع الاثقال التي يمارسها منذ كان
عمره 16 عاما حين تراه وهو يرفع الاثقال
في صلاه للالعاب الرياضيه في مدينه صيدا
جنوبيه لبنان تظنه في انفوان الشباب ولكن
انه سيكمل عامه الثامن بعد ثلاثه اشهر فقط
من اين هذا بطولات المحليه ودوليه
للمحترفين في رفع الاوزان الثقيله لكنه لم
يقبل بترك هذه الرياضه التي بالمواظبه
عليها لم يدخل المستشفى ابدا في الرياضه
في هذا السن كما يقول نشعلك وكانك فتى في
مقتبل العمر هذا النموذج هو نموذج ملهم
ومحفز واحيانا ربما مستفز ليس لمن هم في
سنه فقط بل حتى للشباب
جهوله الذين هاجروا الرياضه ولو مجرد
المشي فما بالك برفع الاثقال متعكم الله
جميعا بالصحه والعافيه تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]